I believe that the Yale School of Public
Health has the chance to Define Public
Health scholarship education and
practice for the next Century to Define
who's part of Public Health how we do it
how we identify and address health
problems in an inclusive Equitable and
impactful way the ultimate objective for
the Yale School of Public Health is for
us to be recognized globally as the
school that is transforming the future
of human health
[Music]
I see there being four pillars of a
School of Public Health that defines the
future of our field those are
inclusivity it is of course core to the
field of Public Health but it's also how
we are going to succeed as we move
forward inclusivity is about having a
diverse Equitable inclusive and
belonging focused environment within our
school for faculty staff and students
but it's also about being inclusive of
Community Voices of lived experience of
folks who we may not traditionally think
of as being part of Public Health at all
Innovation and Entrepreneurship making
sure that we're set up to make sure that
public health Innovations can thrive in
either for-profit or not for profit
environments the third pillar is around
communication as we learned all too well
during coid it's essential for all of us
students faculty and the World At Large
to know how to communicate about public
health and scientific knowledge the last
pillar that is essential for us as we
move forward into the public health
School of the Future is around
datadriven leadership that's the ability
for us to use our disciplinary skills to
identify problems gather data sets to
look at the details and then figure out
what to do next public health is only as
good as the action that we take at the
other side the impact that we have on
the health of our local community as
well as the nation and the globe those
are the skills that we have to impart in
our students but also that we as faculty
and staff and alumni need to be
dedicated
[Music]
to cea Winslow founded our School of
Public Health 108 years ago based on the
idea that core to Public Health is the
community and also core to Public Health
is empowering the community for change
that's one of the philosophies that
informs my leadership style in general
informs my decision to assume the
deanship here at the Yale School of
Public Health and that is core to our
function as a School of Public Health
but going forwards it is incumbent on us
to do more Public Health only succeeds
when we have the public at its core when
we listen to partner with and sometimes
are led by the needs of the communities
in which we
work as an Emergency Physician I know
that I'm only as good as the team that I
work with and so my commitment as a
leader is to making sure that everyone
on my team is set up for Success knows
what their role is and is empowered to
do everything that they can for the
greater
[Music]
good oh here Yale we have tremendous
potential to influence and make progress
on firearm injury prevention both within
the School of Public Health but also in
partnership with other schools across
Yale we have a number of brilliant
researchers at the Yale School of Public
Health who are already thinking about
many of those Baseline risk factors for
firearm injury and how to modify them we
have a tremendous opportunity to set the
standard not just as an academic
Community but as a city and as a state
that can help lead the rest of the
nation thank you from the bottom of my
heart for your commitment to the Yale
School of Public
Health